[Music]
2012 apparently going to be another huge
year for video games so i thought would
give you because we we pride ourselves
on being at the forefront of all things
tech right on the show oh sure i thought
would give you a sneak peek at some of
this year's big releases in a piece we
call new video games i think this is
exciting
first up there's a new call of duty game
that's coming out this year people love
call of duty yeah there's a new one
coming out it's called
call of duty teenage girl edition
yeah
now this time you're a teenage girl and
your mission is to destroy your
frenemies the teenage girl way with
cruel and humiliating personal insults
check it out
nice shoes [ __ ]
the horde convention is to your right
why doesn't it take place in a mall or
something right
why is there still burning wreckage
everywhere
next up is a basketball video game
that's very popular in indiana utah in
boston that's right it's the all-white
guy
nba live
yeah
all white guy nba live it's exciting
game take a look
[Applause]
that's a nail biter yeah yeah
i'd be good attacking yeah
i'd really lean forward cross arms i can
do them both at the same time
this next video game is called world of
w
world of world of warcraft
in this game you control a guy whose
life is going down the tubes because he
can't stop playing world of warcraft
[Applause]
[Music]
this one's really stupid our next video
game
and in this batch that's saying
something
our next video game features celebrities
like andy samberg jesse eisenberg ruth
bader ginsburg and new york mayor mike
bloomberg
it's called angry birds
let's take a look
i i don't know geronimo i guess
once i said it why did we have to see it
because the birds knocked down the pigs
our final video game
our final video game
is keeping away the kardashians that's
right
yeah
this is the most popular one this game
lets you keep the kardashians at bay
using the only weapon that works on them
nba basketball players
those are good